jacques attali
treize enfants bernardin juvénile secret
quand même voté par un pote au tour de
france qui est il des trucs
toute façon puisque ça secret j'ai pas
vous le dire un jour je vous le dirai
cintrée des produits un truc
ouais et puis je vous dirai si vous
voulez les mêmes si cher bernard tapie
va se recycler dans l'anti âge c'est ça
voilà en tout cas ça marche
75 regarde 75 ans
non
voilà bien alors merci d'être là vous
n'avez rien ne rentre non et vous êtes
là par solidarité pour tout le monde en
parle parce que c'est l'avant dernière
émission
larry novembre je suis là quand même
il a quand même demandé trente mille
euros l'équipage je signale que personne
ne me les a donnés sans dans le jardin
non mais c'est vrai franchement ça fait
vraiment plaisir parce que parce que
c'est c'est une émission qui va manquer
beau et donc je suis content de venir
avec vous deux à l'occasion d'un de ces
dernières des voilà merci
bien sûr on va parler politique on va
commencer avec avec le foot avec le
mondial avec les bleus
m
fini
au regard vous expliquer comment cette
métamorphose des bleus dans le match
contre l'espagne il ya plein de raisons
mais on va essayer de sortir les
essentiels la première et la plus
importante c'est le changement total de
psychologie et de motivation quand on
rencontre le togo la corée même la
suisse
les français ont beau se dire et se le
dise il faut gagner on va mettre tout
notre coeur on va mettre toute notre
énergie
ils font appel à ce qu'on appelle la
motivation volontaires celles qui
dépendent sa volonté
quand tu rends compte que l'espagne et
qu' il s'agit de passer un cap et
surtout de remettre les pendules à
l'heure là c'est tu fais appel à la
motivation inconsciente
celle qui le fait courir le 100 mètres
parce que ton gosse se noie 1
la vraie différence assez clap qui font
ils font appel à des ressources que
seule la volonté ne peut pas de données
or quand on sait qu'un être humain
utilise à peine la moitié de ses
potentialités
sur un match comme ça tu obtiens les
trucs bon alors ensuite l'espagne eux
ont vécu le contraire on aura mis la
tête comme ça c'est les futurs champions
du monde ce qui fait que malgré
l'ouverture du score aurait pu leur
permettre de temporiser un peu de jouer
les malins de rester derrière et vas-y
on continue on continue et ils nous ont
donné des boulevards derrière que les
français ont bien su exploiter ses
énormes
ces normes parce que on a vu ce que ça a
généré chez les gens c'est l'imaginaire
c est une belle démonstration de ce que
les gens sont capables de faire lorsqu
on leur offre un événement qui verra un
bill à thouars les services devraient en
tout les français sont derrière
l'incroyable sais pas si tu as eue dans
les rues par tours 1 c'était une c'est
un bonheur exprimé sans limite et qu'on
voit pas dans l'autre dans d'autres
formes d'existence ce que le sport et en
particulier le football
moi je vois jamais des gens qui se
connaissent pas dans la rue qui
s'embrassent et c'est la grande certains
quartiers les boîtes privées
alors derrière cette émission est
enregistré exceptionnellement avant
france brésil
puisqu'on est jeudi soit la voilà donc
tu vas me donner un pronostic et
l'hommage bien le finir
ouais c'est horrible objectivement je ne
sais juste à l'invitation mer noire
parce que je ne peux que te dire voilà
ce qui va se passer un sûrement un et te
dire je souhaite tellement j'ai
tellement envie qu'on gagne que je te
fais pas de pronostics je te fais que
mon souhait ouais ouais j'ai vraiment la
trouve
j'ai vraiment peur parce que réellement
sur le papier autant n'ya pas une autre
équipe
franchement y'a pas une autre équipe qui
nous est supérieure
bien sûr le papier sur le papier le
brésil nous est supérieur alors
maintenant est ce que cette espèce de
confiance convient de prendre cette
espèce de 2,2 volonté de ne rien avoir à
faire parce que maintenant ils ont fait
l'essentiel on est en quart de finale
contre le brésil
celui qui gagne là un dur à battre le
fait que l'arbitré espagnol conneries
pour nous à difficile difficile en ce
moment il a également géré les espagnols
arbitres espagnols
moi je pense que y'aura forcément à dire
sur l'arbitrage
un malheureux toi c'est quoi commentant
la merde parce que c'est le coucher du
soleil c'est quoi l'oiseau derrière
jeudi un merle
mais c'est génial quand à la tombée du
jour c'est le milanais j'étais sûr que
non
je ne connais pas les saisons la nature
tout ça tu connais pas ta mère l'aurait
jamais rld genou jean néret dans mon
jardin ici peu de jeanne moreau ip je
lui fais tous les jours et moi je finis
zana la la la
on est devenus potes vous pensez quoi
des condamnations dans le procès des
comptes de l'om bernard tapie et je veux
qu'on pensait la même chose que quand
elle s'adressait à moi
elles ont strictement aucun sens tu peux
pas condamner robert louis dreyfus pour
abus de bien social dans son club dans
lequel il a mis 130 millions d'euros
je veux dire faut être un peu que si le
frêne qui peut l'accuser plein de choses
éventuellement d'art fait des contrats
bidons d'avoir arnaqué gels et l'urssaf
que les joueurs et triché sur les impôts
je suppose qu'il doit y avoir dans le
dossier des choses mais ils n'ont pas
retenu là dessus donc ça veut dire qu'il
était coupable de rien d'autre que ça et
là c'est du délire
on peut pas reprocher à un mec d'avoir
été puisque le des vidals 8 bien c'est
d'avoir porté tort à son entreprise en
gros en gros un tu porteras ton
entreprise quand tu mets 150 millions
d'euros dans les caisses au le maillot
vert donc ça tient pas debout alors à
suite si on veut parler des systèmes qui
tourne autour du foot en france je parle
tous les clubs ont recours aux mêmes
arnaque qui consiste à pouvoir faire des
salaires concurrentiels avec les
étrangers qui paye moins d'impôts
voilà tout le problème est là quand un
joueur est sur le point de venir en
angleterre en espagne en italie ou en
france
il choisit un autre pays que le nôtre
parce qu'il est plus taxé alors
puisqu'on parlait tout à l'heure ça va
vous intéresser
on parlait tout à l'heure des pronostics
et bien je vais vous dire pourquoi la
france est devenue un petit pays de
football l'angleterre tous les joueurs
de l'équipe anglaise joue en angleterre
mais qui dit à sauf beckham l'italie
tous les joueurs l'écrivain italienne
journe italie l'espagne tous les joueurs
l'espagne joue en espagne
les allemands tous les joueurs allemands
jouent en allemagne les français trois
joueurs français jouent en france on a
rejoint le peloton des pays sous
développés
c'est qu'à cause des impôts ils sont
vides les jurés ans et que ça et c'est
globalement c'est un fossé les contrôles
c'est l'urssaf
c'est un pays qui devient pu tellement
pressurisée que les gens ont envie
d'aller ailleurs et ce qui se passe dans
le football ne vous faites pas
oh c'est comme ça pour les artistes qui
peuvent partir ailleurs c'est comme ça
pour tous les autres sportifs de haut
niveau c'est comme ça pour les grands
chercheurs c'est comme ça pour les
grands ingénieurs et ça va finir par
être comme ça par pour tout le monde
tu vas plus personne peut-elle y aura
six il y aura ceux qui veulent un
attendent des autres leur salut
personnel
mais est ce que cette crise de confiance
envers l'équipe de france finalement ne
traduit pas ne reflète pas une crise de
confiance du pays en lui-même
les français sont très bizarre parce que
il rien sondage sur la croyance le
bonheur et c'est à qui m'a vachement est
à tcc ça dans le challenge début de
l'année question êtes vous plutôt
heureux plutôt malheureux 80 2 % des
gens plutôt heureux 4 deuxième question
pensez vous que les français sont plutôt
heureux
malheureux il pense que 82% des français
sont mal ses démons et thouars mais en
schizophrénie total ça veut dire que
toutes les nouvelles toutes les infos
qu'ils sont ce qu'elles sont on va pas
reprocher aux journaux télévisés le dire
qu'il ya tant de morts par le sida qu il
ya le tsunami etc
n'empêche que leurs impressions à eux
c'est de vivre au milieu d'une tempête
incroyable qui fait que tout le monde
doit être dans une merde noire m on doit
souffrir et pas nous mais c'est pas vrai
je veux dire c'est un des gros problèmes
qui rend ce pays très compliqué à gérer
c'est pour ça que c'est un pays où il ya
un taux de suicide très important c'est
le plus gros consommateurs
d'antidépresseurs au monde la france est
simple ouais c'est vrai que au moment
des trente glorieuses
on a eu un modèle social très développé
qui était vraiment bien bien installés
qui était basé sur le partage sur le
fait que tout le monde doit profiter au
moins en ce qui concerne l'éducation la
santé la justice
des progrès qui sont faits et puis ils
ont pris pour beaucoup l'habitude d'être
un peu ce qu'on ne saurai zain peut
assister quand ils se sentent plus dans
cette situation de sécurité beaucoup
perdre les pédales
on est aussi un des pays où le divorce
fait le plus de ravages et crée des
situations dramatiques quand un couple
sans moyens divorcé il ya des mecs qui
couchent dans la bagnole parce que il
donc de quoi payer un appartement pas
deux évidemment heureusement on laisse
la femme dans l'appartement avec les
enfants et le mec il a plu en haut lieu
d'eau donc en dehors de la souffrance
affective
il ya une souffrance matériel terrible
mais il ya un sondage dans le mail
observateurs dont on parlait ici la
semaine dernière déjà moi qui me qui
m'étonne complètement ses êtes vous
favorable ou non à l'économie de marché
alors en chine ses 74 % des chinois sont
favorables à la commune marché aux états
unis ses 71 % dans les grands pays
européens à ses 65 66 % et en france et
34 % le risque que la france est très en
avance et elle a compris que le
capitalisme s'étaient pas bien et lé
post capitaliste ou au contraire elle
est très en retard
j'ai un problème non mais d'abord il est
possible qu'il existe un système
beaucoup plus efficace plus généreux qui
rend les gens plus heureux qu'on le
connaît pas un puisque pour l'instant on
a mis en opposition le marxisme qui a
généré un socialiste puis une
social-démocratie et puis la loi du
marché encore une fois la loi du marché
pour les gens c'est l'abandon d'une
certaine sécurité et d'une certaine
protection à plat jacquot mon pays le
plus protégé
forcément les français sont les plus
opposés à le demeurer
ensuite il ya l'interprétation qu'on se
fait dans le mot la loi du marché pour
beaucoup la loi du marché c'est la loi
de la jungle et il faut reconnaître que
par certains égards c'est un peu vrai
alors est-ce que le français est plus
malin plus impertinent plus rigoureux
pour exiger davantage c'est un peu tout
ça près maintenant il faut que ces fonds
c'est là se disent que s'il existe une
autre technique une autre méthode c'est
pas la france qui pourra l'imposé seul
parce qu'elle fait 2 % du monde la vraie
donc dans un monde qui est entièrement
soumis à la loi du marché
on est obligé de l'adopter c'est du
baratin alors on a des mecs j'entends
besancenot j'entends tout ça c'est bien
c'est c'est rafraîchissant mais
entendent dénoncer lui font quoi que
dalkia france un peu le village
d'astérix aujourd'hui c'est lui qui l'a
dit les patrons faut tous les virer
1 on les remplacera ouais par quoi par
d'autres patrons 1 qui auront une
nouvelle hiérarchie toute la société
basée sur une hiérarchie que tu tues
mais 150 mec
sur une plage tu les laisses un an et
demi tu reviens il ya un patron il ya
deux adjoints puis elle connard ans
bafoue tous parce qu'il sait pas quoi
faire et la société doit être bien
organisé parce que celui qui est en bas
il a le droit aussi vivre deux pas de
piétiner d'être protégé qu'on lui passe
ont dû pour une baisse pas sa femme il a
le droit
alors c'est là où la société doit être
organisé pour faire face à la limite aux
aux inégalités de la hiérarchie mais
mirarchi elle existe dans les pays
socialistes y avait une hiérarchie dans
les pays capitalistes une hiérarchie la
france est un pays qui s'accommode mal
des hiérarchies pays assez égalitariste
la france bat on lui a fait sa
conception comme ça c'est un fait
logique alors en tous les cas tout ça
donne aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
une importance considérable à huy
falloir faire attention programme là
parce qu'après abbas et moi je pense
franchement qu'on n'est pas dans la
situation dramatique qu'on raconte
nous on n'est pas bien et là il va
falloir être très prudent je crois que
c'est ma réaction là sont les dernières
où on a le droit de se tromper alors
vous vous n'avez pas revenir en
politique pourtant vous êtes éligibles
depuis trois ans mais voulait parvenir
est ce que vous avez peur vous dit quand
je voulais devenir maire de marseille on
a trouvé 100 mille francs dans un jardin
pour m'envoyer en prison l'affairé mua
si je suis candidat à la présidentielle
on va mettre 100 kilos de cocaïne dans
mon coffre fait pas sens parce que l'on
coop ne tient pas mais quelques kilos
n'aurait c'est une manière de dire que
on
ne veut pas tout le monde est finalement
bombay dont elles ont ils veulent rester
entre eux c'est un métier de faire de la
politique
les professionnels de la politique ont
toujours une distance à l'égard de ceux
qui viennent pas de leurs rangs mais
c'est vrai de kouchner c'est vrai de
borloo c'est vrai de tapis c'est vrai de
tous ceux qui à un moment donné ont eu
envie de franchir le pas est-ce que
c'est légitime
quelque part oui quelques parle oui
parce que on n'a pas donné en tout cas
de gages sur la réalité de nos
convictions notre programmation etc
par conséquent on peut croire que on est
capable de séduire sur des éléments
d'appréciation qui justifie pas le vote
c'est pour ça que les électeurs feront
une grande distinction entre la côte
d'amour avec des sondages extraordinaire
un kouchner
oui le vote 1 le vote c'est une opinion
la cote d'amour c'est une humeur 1
ça nous ramène d'ailleurs à faire
attention aux sondages alors vous n'avez
pas revenir en politique bernard mais
vous allez intervenir d'abord au nom des
trois millions de gens qui ont voté pour
vous serre la sépare du sondage
l'humeur d'une minute un essai du
bulletin dans l'urne à et puis peut-être
aussi au nom du parti radical de gauche
non c'est là que je suis parti parce que
c'est la philosophie radicale entre
parenthèses qui est peu développée on a
l'impression qu'il existe plus de 2 mais
le radicalisme c'est justement c'est
faux souvenirs c'est gambetta des séries
c'est mon ex france et l'école publique
obligatoire elle appelle séparation de
l'église et de l'état
parce je veux dire c'est des choses
encore quand le dal le radicalisme qui
privilégie l'homme plutôt que les
systèmes qui met l'homme au centre de
ses préoccupations de ces débats qui
considère qu' un état une nation est
forte que par l'addition de ces valeurs
individuelles
elle reconnaît donc la valeur
individuelle comme un élément
d'appréciation mais à condition que les
intérêts individuels soient compatibles
avec l'intérêt collectif normale en
termes un peu plus simple ça veut dire
quoi
chacun se démerde chacun c'est d'être le
meilleur on doit pas envisager une
égalité par le bas rhin mais
face à la scolarité donc à
l'apprentissage face à la santé face à
la justice
on doit tous et égaux le chanceux le
malchanceux l'intelligent le conte tout
le monde si la règle c'est la règle pays
c'est la réponse est ce que la belle
langue mais c'est simplement alors en
2007 vous croyez vous à un match
sarko ségo pour l'instant il est plus
que probable les secours avec les mecs
comme langue comme fabius comme strauss
kahn fait quinze ans les mecs qui sont
là qui rament voudrait qu'ils vont
laisser ségolène royal leur piquer non
seulement je crois le blessé mais alors
là pour le coup je comprends rien à la
stratégie du parti socialiste rien c'est
le contraire justement de ce qu'on
disait alors du radicalisme l'élection
présidentielle
c'est un candidat ou une candidate qui
se présente d'or les français qui fait
une proposition qui dit voilà la société
tel que je l'imaginé et qui s'entoure
des gens pour la mettre en place le
parti socialiste commence à te dire
voilà le programme on se met tous
d'accord sur un programme
bon on est tous d'accord pour dire à une
chose et après comme un casting comme un
film un film tu fais le scénario et
après tu as le metteur en scène commence
à choisir les acteurs mais c'est de la
folie
chaque candidat socialiste à la
candidature devrait faire son programme
passer devant les militants pour que les
militants c'est vrai autonome et un
programme et non pas pour un homme ou
une femme sur un même programme
c'est ça qui les amène d'abord à dire
n'importe quoi tu as vu ségolène est
toujours à 1000m cieux mais amélie qui
fera sa des méchas ligne alapage il y en
a pas un qui pense pareil
or les sons ségolène royal vendre son
programme celui auquel elle croain si
les militants socialistes en vole pas
ils peuvent préférer strauss kahn qui ne
manque pas de qualités qui manquent pas
d'idées ou fabuleuse qui manque pas de
qualités du manque pas d'idées et après
par la loi normale de respecter le vote
des militants tout le monde se met neuf
candidats et son programme plutôt que ça
alors ta ségolène qui est pour on sert
un peu la vis
le parti socialiste est là on sert pas
la vis
ta ségolène qui est pour le mariage nom
de déconne pas on est contre le mariage
tu comprends plus rien c'est du délire
sigolène vous la connaissez bien ouais
et sympa près elle parle de blair mais
faut pas vous faire d'illusions elle est
socialiste
à oui oui oui oui vrai de vrai alors ce
qu'aime saab allez-y les mecs et que
sarkozy veut être copains vers là non
plus non non je laime bien ouais je le
connais on se connaît et lui aussi c'est
un candidat redoutable mais lui il est
dans une configuration qui est plus
facile parce que l'ump c'est devenu son
parti il est à la fois prescripteurs des
idées de son parti et récepteurs de ce
que le son parti propose autrement dit
il va nous faire une programmation qui
en main de ce qu'ils ressentent et des
hommes qui vont le soutenir pour le
faire donc là il est plus à l'aise pour
aller devant les électeurs que quelqu'un
qui va défendre un programme qui n'est
pas le sien
donc je dirais que normalement on a plus
de chance alors c'est peut-être une
bonne ou mauvaise chose
chaque français fera ce qu'il veut mais
vous avez plus de chance de voir sarkozy
faire ce qui va dire qu'il va faire
ouais quand les socialistes que les
socialistes parce que lui il a toutefois
laissé son programme et a vu que je sais
par revient pays cette semaine
oui j'ai vu dans la même semaine on a
quand même eu les résidents qui a
annoncé qui dira s'il est candidat au
1er trimestre 2007 mais et jospin qui
nous dit officiellement ce qui la part
était d'ouvrir faut quand même dire que
ça fait un an qu'ils nous dit un autre
témoin ou givet et si vous m'appelez je
vais y aller donc on vous rendez compte
on va peut être assister à une un autre
france-brésil quoi ça va de nouveau le
combat des chefs prime et non jospin je
crois qu'il se met hors jeu en faisant
ça il se met pas hors jeu en étant
candidat il se met hors jeu en annonçant
qui peut l'être si on va le chercher
parce qu'il aurait pu très bien
ne pas annoncer qu'il était candidat
avant qu'on le demande
et là ils avaient une légitimité quelque
part pourquoi
d'abord parce que il croit pas un
instant que ségolène royal est capable
il dit pas qu'elle va pas gagner
il estime tout le monde sait qui la
considère pas capable de pression de
république
deuxièmement il pense que les
communistes les verts les extrêmes
gauche etc
il a à peu près le seul à pouvoir faire
la gauche plurielle espèce d gauche
plurielle donc s'il avait été
effectivement demandé sans qu'ils
disaient c'était crédible mais là ils
leur demandent qu'on l'appelle alors
qu'on le demande pas je crois qu'il
s'est disqualifiée je crois que les gens
lui en veulent en plus de cette barre en
2002 qua non ils lui en veulent pas de
cette barre en 2002 il a eu une attitude
au contraire honorable j'allais dire
ligne un minimum que tous les politiques
devraient avoir moi le jour où j'ai été
mis hors la politique pour les anguilles
savez je me suis mis même si maintenant
je suis éligible
1 je considère qu'on peut pas dire bah
tiens je suis fini je reviens il a été
porteur d'un échec terrible il
il en a souffert terriblement il a eu le
seul comportement digne que tous les
hommes politiques n'auraient pas vouloir
pour ça allons il a été le contraire il
en pleine forme à nancy 10 dans les
finalement je vais peut-être me
renouvelle danois là ça sent à présent
des quand même tendance à puis vous
serez candidat de toute façon dont le
film de fabien onteniente et qui
s'appelle le candidat justement j'ai
adoré ce mec il rencontré un il m'a dit
qu'est ce que tu prépares tu d'une pièce
on man s'appelle le candidat il m'a dit
non tu fais un film avec moi 1 il est
vraiment génial donc on va faire un film
ensemble à la rentrée là et j'ai bien
aimé le son approche il à la jane bonne
idée alors j'ai déclaré j'ai connu la
vie avec beaucoup d'argent je la connais
maintenant ce sens je préfère la vie
avec et ben ça vous étonne pas tout est
mieux c'est vachement mieux c'est
vachement mieux parce que les gens
essaient de mettre en opposition
l'argent une bonne heure par exemple
évidemment si tu me dis tu préfères
riches ou en bonne santé
ça suppose que tu es riche et malade oui
préférait pauvres en bonne santé mais
t'es pas obligé d'être malade parce que
tu es riche un grand oui mais
en bonne santé richard bonne santé
pauvres c'est une union bones ont péri
mais c'est tout mieux arrêter de
déconner dakar dak'art non mais vous
ballon et vous non mais c'est mieux
d'avoir de l'argent dit prévoir vous
dites maintenant je connais la vie sans
argent
ça veut dire quoi c'est bien d'avoir un
salaire qui correspond à un salaire de
cadre
on n'est pas plus non puisque tout le
reste c'est voler ah non mais quoi que
vous gagnez maintenant bah ouais et
courbis vous trouvez qu'il était trop
lourdement condamnés en lan tu as eu ont
mis deux ans de prison
ouais c'est pour faire ouais et puis la
récupérer sur six d'avant il a récupéré
18 mois il a dû faire une chose
vachement grave quand même pour moi rami
n'en parlons en rasant et demi c'est en
trois brèves qu'on donne à un type qui
viole selon qu'il a dû faire des trucs
terribles mais je crois pas qu'il ait
fénart terrible vous avez bien rolland
oui j'aime beaucoup
bernanke a dit on va faire une arbid ue